Get ready with me
for the last day of Charleston Wine and Food Festival.
This has been a whirlwind weekend,
and honestly,
the staff has had to pivot a couple of times
because of terrible weather here in Charleston.
But that doesn't rain on our parade,
because we are still going to the day party today,
and we're gonna have a great time.
This is my first year covering
the Charleston Wine and Food Festival as an influencer,
and I couldn't be more excited.
One of my favorite things about living in Charleston
is the food.
In all honesty,
if there's ever an event where they're like, hey,
you can show up and drink wine and eat food,
and it counts as work,
I'm there today.
My husband is coming with me to the day party,
which is going to be held in Mount Pleasant
on the waterfront.
Hopefully it's not gonna be too windy,
because I have this cute little strawberry
hat that I've been wanting to wear all festival.
You know your girl loves a theme.
Besides all the fabulous food and drinks,
I have really been enjoying meeting and hanging out
with some of my favorite influencers here in Charleston.
There is such a sense of community amongst all of us.
It is awesome to see.
So although I'm tired,
let's rally and have a great day.